what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
fresh and fit podcast
labeled society lies two girls i'm a
girl
i want to know what i've been lied to
about i have my own opinions on like
what society does lie to about girls but
i'm curious to see
if i agree with fresh and fit because as
you know
the hosts are a little too douchey for
me i'm sorry i said it
they seem like they they're driven got a
good head on their shoulders
just not my cup of tea so i'm curious if
we have the same like thoughts on this
stuff
before i start do not forget to like
comment and subscribe
especially subscribe to the channel um
as you guys know i'm trying to grow
every single day
i really really appreciate it and
comment what do you think
society lies to women about okay
let's see what is up with this
what's up guys martin gaines uh let me
turn down the sound
freshman ceo today we're going to talk
about why women are delusional in the
dating game
this will be a good one guys let's get
into it
all right guys so you've heard the
stories before you heard the classical
laneigh podcast of females wanting all
these standards right
but guess what what did they bring to
the table when i say
nothing it is nothing they're just
bringing their looks they're bringing oh
i can cook
i can clean if they even say that if
they even say that
right that's a very small majority of
these people right
however guess what right if you're a
high value guy you can always hire
a maid you can hire a cook so what if
you bring the table other than herpes
leave
if you guys want what have you been to
the table and guess what
not much if anything at all so question
is
why it is so delusional but guess what
i'll tell you why they've met
an alpha dude or a guy has stuff
together and
that one experience i said you know what
it's type guy that i want
okay number one why do i get grouped in
with the girls from miami
my goodness what happened to the average
females
okay number two i'm gonna let them
finish before i read
that's what they go after and it's
important to intimate because guess what
now everybody see our date is that type
of guy
so they don't see the vast majority of
guys that are working hard nine to five
doing their thing because they want to
see the top
level guys that had one experience with
one time yeah guys i mean at the end of
the day the reality is this
okay you wanna know why women are
delusional because they've been lied to
their whole life okay
okay i actually do agree with the
they'll get attention from like a higher
level guy and they'll think they're on a
higher level than they are i
i've definitely seen that in like my own
life and in like girls that i know at
the time she was little girl
hey you can do anything a boy can do and
better
you know what you can go to school you
can do everything that a man can do and
better
college you could do anything a man can
do and better hey you want to chase your
career
go for it make that money you can also
be a super mom as well
you can make a lot of money you can get
the man of your dreams
guys i'm here to tell you and for the
few ladies out there what like our two
female subscribers
two percent women i'm right here
i'm here i don't know if i subscribed to
them but i'm here i think i did i think
i did
as i'm lied to you right and the reality
is this guys
the reason why women are so delusional
is because they've been told their
entire life
they're perfect the way they are and
that they can do anything
a man can do i always say this on the
podcast
okay i don't agree well i'm trying to
think
i really wasn't grown up like saying
that you could have like the perfect guy
the perfect job perfect
everything but i will okay let me
put this in like a guy's perspective if
you're a guy
and you constantly have like nine and
ten models coming up to you
and offering let's say offering
relationships to you
but no because what guys want sex right
and you think like you're gonna get sex
out of it and you don't
that's like the equivalent of what
happens to girls so a nine or ten guy
will come up to them and offer them sex
and they'll think they're going to get a
relationship out of it and they don't
and then you want to say like oh like
those girls like shouldn't be so
delusional
but just for like if you were in their
shoes and that was happening to you
you would probably be a little bit
delusional too
especially with like the hook up in like
college culture
which is very um
like everything is more casual and it's
a lot more normal to like
hook up before you're in a relationship
not saying that's the way it should be
i'm like very
i believe in like more traditional stuff
but like
does that make sense like you can see
how it happens is my point
men live in a fact-based reality while
women live in a bizarro world
and what i mean by they live in a
bizarre world is they're not really held
accountable for their actions i know
that's true
toxic masculinity okay i'm not gonna say
toxic masculinity
men and women aren't held accountable
for certain things
um for example
a lot of times men are held accountable
for cheating
but women cheat too so bad people do bad
things it's not
all specific women aren't held
accountable i'll tell you guys so the
biggest example of women not being held
accountable
the body positivity movement you want to
put benefits from the body positivity
movement
women women not men bro if you're a fat
dude
people are going to clown you hey bro
you got titties hey bro you got a gut
or worse yet you're just not going to
get laid however with women
if they're overweight it's okay girl
love your curves
you're beautiful the way you are blah
blah blah women are never told hey
you need to lose some weight baby girl
that is considered toxic
that's considered rude toxic
misogynistic
okay it's not real okay i don't i'm like
with him
i think and i'm not skinny guys if
you've seen any of like my full
body pictures on my instagram i don't
edit that [ __ ]
i'm not tiny like i probably could lose
10 to 20 pounds
so i'm not even coming from a place of
like a skinny girl but
the body positivity movement basically
is just people were tired of being told
they're fat all the time
and even when i was growing up like all
if you look at the early 2000s like
media those girls were so
skinny and i remember i'm six foot i was
like 150 140 pounds for a while
and i remember feeling that like looking
at that stuff so
in my opinion like the body positivity
movement was like an extreme
that came from like
this extreme like skinny body type and
people were just kind of tired of like
you know feeling like they weren't good
enough right um
so i understand it i don't agree like i
don't think
and this is coming from someone that
like really isn't that thin
like people telling me that i'm skinny
is gonna make me believe that i'm skinny
and beautiful just the way i am
i'm working on it i'm trying to i'm
training for a half marathon
but like i understand like
what their thought process is because i
don't think you should be going around
telling people they should lose weight
like that's their body they can do what
they want it doesn't affect you
but then they'll turn around and tell
you oh i only date guys that are six
feet tall
but if you say hey i don't want a girl
that's fat oh my god
you're toxical okay two things
i don't think it's toxic to say that you
want to date somebody that's thin
because when you think about it if you
date somebody that's not in shape and
not healthy
you're going to be if you actually want
to stay married to them for a lifetime
you're going to spend the last half of
your life
taking care of them bad health like
that's
really hard in a relationship second
thing
i also i don't see a problem if girls
want to date tall guys
however and this is coming from someone
that's tall
it probably would help a lot of girls to
expand their options
to guys that are shorter because that's
not going to make him a good husband
that's not going to make him kind loyal
whatever
like none of those traits are specific
to being tall
and the tall guys you're going gonna
have to like compete more with
um i mean again a girl people will
probably say that i'm full of it because
i'm dating a guy who's 6-3
but that's just my two cents
you know bumble literally just came out
with a rule recently yeah
where you can't mention that you don't
want fat girls in your profile as a man
guys i'm telling you i'm telling you you
shouldn't put that anyway just swipe
left like you look so
douchey when you put no fat girls
society
makes the world a bizarro existence for
women man they don't live in reality a
lot of the times they don't no matter
how poorly behaved they are
no matter how rude they are no matter
the
uh men no matter mental the
no matter their mental state because
let's make no mistake about it
statistics show
one in four women is on some kind of
antidepressant or anxiety medication
okay no matter how nice they are no
matter how they
are i'd be curious out of the one and
four how many are overweight because i
guarantee the two
go hand in hand i'm not a naturally
anxious person
like i mean i am but like i struggle the
most with anxiety
and i'm not even like diagnosed or
anything crazy like that it's just
something i struggle with
i struggle with it with it the most when
i am eating terrible i've noticed
society does not
punish them for it whereas if you're a
man and you have these problems
you're fat you have mental deficiencies
you are not a high earner you're a loser
whatever it is no one cares no one cares
and as a matter of fact society clowns
you for it which you know what i think
they should because if you're not
performing as a man
you need to be held accountable for it
but you know what needs to go both ways
because last time i checked
womanism is here to make things equal
right but here's the thing
they don't want equality guys they want
equality of outcome
okay that's the difference so with that
said guys
the reason why they're delusional is
because they've been told a set of lies
their entire life that they can have it
all
then the next thing you know they're 40
years old making 200 grand a year with a
kid or two calling us to kevin samuels
show saying like where did all the good
man go and guys it's because women don't
get hit with this harsh reality
that they are measured on their looks
and their femininity and their
submissiveness
over their career accomplishments until
they're older and they no longer get
that attention that they used to get
in their 20s so guys like i said women
live in a bizarre world
it is what it is you got to continue
living in the fact-based world
where you're judged on your performance
and what you bring to the table as a man
women don't learn these hard truths
until later on in life and by then a lot
of the time
is too late be lucky that you're
watching our channel learning us now
while you're still young or when you can
still make changes because as a man
it's never too late you can always
improve your value you just have to be
dedicated to do it right
right so guys we'll catch you okay
you know what's interesting half the
channels that i watch are literally made
for me
even before i like watched this video
most of the youtube videos like i
watched world made for men
um but anyways he has some good points
um i definitely agree with him that like
a lot of times women are put in like a
delusional light
and i think it's because women are more
agreeable and so we really don't
like to tell each other the harsh truths
you know because when we go to our
friends we're going to our friends for
emotional support and security
not to be told the harsh truth i'm just
being honest
like yeah
um let me know in the comments though do
you what
oh my gosh i can't talk
what are the biggest lies that women are
told and what should women
do about it let me know in the comments
don't forget to subscribe
talk to you guys next